the sea of grease poses a puzzling
question was a disturbing answer more
migrant boats are leaving Turkey for the
EU but on the Greek island of Lesbos
there hasn't been an increase in
arrivals there were 19 people on this
boat a 16 year old from Afghanistan
filmed these pictures he said it was
shortly after masked men attacked them
from a dinghy the boat was in Greek
waters off lesbos on the 5th of June
this year the boy doesn't want to be
identified because two men have mystic
they are wearing black masks on their
faces and the one half knife they just
make a hole on our boat and cut the the
wire which is connected with engine we
analyzed dozens of similar reports and
videos comparing them with geo data such
as Coast lines in the position of the
Sun along with information from
emergency calls official reports and
eyewitness accounts our conclusion
refugees and migrants are being kept
away from the Greek coast at times by
force
it seems masked men often attack migrant
boats on the open seas damaging them so
they can't be steered and leaving them
adrift sometimes they even actively
forced the boats back into Turkish
waters a tactic known as push back these
push backs illegal intensed
international law but it's difficult to
establish for certain who this masked
man actually are even though the
evidence is apparently overwhelming
evidence such as this video a detailed
analysis of both structures let our
colleagues from the investigative
platform spelling head and lighthouse
reports to clearly identify the dinghy
as belonging to Greek Coast Guard ship
but Greece denies using illegal methods
the Coast Guard 2tw
the operations conducted by a harbor
police and Hellenic Coast Guard are in
accordance with international law and
international conventions we also asked
the European Border Agency Frontex which
works closely with the Greek Coast Guard
their answer didn't refer to the
incidents in question they just said all
of their border control operations
conformed to the highest standards my
question to context you say you don't
know but how could you not know and what
steps have you taken to rebut what we
have as evidence
Hanna Kiki has been watching migrants
moving across the G in C for years and
has seen a rise in the number of push
backs she has been monitoring the
situation for the European Center for
Constitutional and human rights the EU
is expected to stand up for new law to
be respected and we haven't seen that we
haven't seen it in public statements
made by representatives of EU
institutions and we haven't seen it in
any sort of legal action that you
institutions have the power to take
against Member States not respecting
euro members of the European Parliament
and the UN High Commission for Refugees
are demanding an official investigation
they say Greece has the right to defend
its borders but it must do so within
international law and notice min Taraki
Greek Minister for immigration and
Asylum joins us now from Athens thank
you for being with us
Minister Mataura he is the Greek Coast
Guard actively pushing back migrants in
the Aegean Sea absolutely not we fully
abide by international and
European law regarding the protection of
Italian seekers and refugees we're
facing a crisis we experienced 9800
arrivals in 2020 a large number as you
would understand for the overcrowded
comes in the island in our solemn
services but we are protecting our
borders the Coast Guard is actively
there to protect human life at sea and I
am pleased to report it in 2020 we have
the fewer loss of life ever in the
Aegean
we have only lost one person in the
entire first half of 2020 still
regrettable but a positive development
for the protection of human life you may
have seen those pictures of masked men
pushing back those boats in the Aegean
Sea indeed what appears to be attacking
the migrants in those boats is Greece
using proxies to do that do you know who
those men in those boats are and how
they got there I haven't seen the
pictures really Ferring up were not
using naturally any proxies the Hellenic
Coast Guard and frontex and occasionally
NATO are there to protect the sea
borders of the European Union you will
know that since March we faced an
organized aggression from our neighbors
the attempt to cross more than 150,000
people in Everest was well-organized and
the entire leadership of the European
Union the presidency of cancel the
presidency of the Commission and the
presidency of the country you know world
there to demonstrate the Solidarity of
the European Union you know I want to
talk about using them I think as a
political tool for geopolitical
objective that clearly is an issue for
the European Union and we understand
Thursday the European Parliament in the
plenary will be discussing an EP
initiative regarding Terex aggression
but you feel left to learn by the rest
of the EU in dealing with the migrants
coming to Greece I think there is not
sufficient support for relocating people
from the frontline States to the rest of
Europe
we currently have a hundred and one
thousand asylum seekers in Greece you
understand for the asylum services that
you'd burden 438 comes that's a big
number we would need more support for
other countries to help us with asylum
seekers and refugees but at the same
time you understand most European
countries are not actively participating
in a mechanism for the relocation of
asylum seekers and refugees and that's
something that we need to work for in
the new rate migration part as well as
the common returns policy minister
maitake thank you very much for talking
with us that was notice matura greece
Minister for immigration and Asylum our
correspondent Barbara basil joins us now
from Brussels from on this story hey
Barbara it appears that there's
overwhelming evidence of these push
backs essentially people being denied to
come ashore which is illegal so why has
there been no outcry from the ranks of
the EU
I mean you observers here Christine
called the reaction of the official
European Union union a deafening silence
there has been some reaction now because
just on this Monday the European
Parliament put this on the agenda and
within one of its committees and the
Commissioner for Refugees of a Johannsen
was heard and she said yes of course the
European Union cannot defend its borders
and at the same time violate its its
regulations its laws its values and so
she called again for these events to be
investigated the problem here is who's
going to do that basically even when the
UNHCR last the the refugee organization
of the United Nations a few weeks ago
called on Greece to investigate these
events it is it ends up with Greece
investigating itself the European Union
simply has no prosecutor it doesn't have
a police it doesn't have the the
possibilities to do this in an active
manner and so this is something that
sort of turns in itself and I shall we
get to a infringement procedure it takes
a long time we are just sort of running
in circles right yeah
believe what I'm hearing but okay so why
is the EU having so much trouble
agreeing on a common refugee policy and
a communist silent policy Barbara that
is quite simple because it is the most
toxic issue ever in the European Union
it's even worse than talking about money
since the refugee so-called refugee
crisis in 2015 and this has been sort of
kicked up and around and about and since
some Eastern European countries for most
Hungary are blocking every attempt to
find a common solution and other
countries hide behind that and say okay
if they don't participate we are not
going to take in people every attempt at
redistribution of refugees relocation of
refugees whatever on a communal level
fails there have been some single
incidences where a group of the Willing
has said okay we'll take some people in
this is a big humanitarian issue at the
moment we need to solve it but in the
end this is no closer to as serious a
real and a fair solution than it was
five years ago and it seems like a
relatively hopeless case Barbara so
what's been the ears response to the
demands that the the Greek government's
army is making they're going to throw up
their hands like they've done in the
past was Italy I mean same problems
there we've seen it I mean the whole
right-wing populists development in
Italy was fueled by this lack of
solidarity and yes it is there it is
it exists it's it's a simple truth
European countries are not willing to
take in the relatively large numbers and
take refugees off the front line
countries hands and they are not they
haven't done it and they are not likely
to do it in the future so this situation
is just simply standing still and it is
not likely to be resolved and that is
what creates things and events like
these push backs because the frontline
country is nothing we have to help
ourselves and we create these very nasty
events and incidents that are after all
illegal but it is not the political
fault of the countries that are involved
in it it is the fault of the whole
European Union in a way
all right that's Bob Rivera in Brussels
Thank You Barbara